welcome to this video playing cowbell
tasks from Denmark played him before one
game one win yeah so I could set up the
maracas see point which I really like
yeah yeah I do that it's just a good
opening I mean I'd like to offer some
variety of our systems but I cannot pass
up to play mine probably my favorite
opening for white it's simply because I
have such an enormous score with it
never lost the tournament game in the
mirach cn1 I cannot count it at least I
don't remember losing a game you tend to
you tend to forget those experiences
those unfortunate experiences but I
really don't remember that I hadn't lost
the game there okay the night c2 line
here we have here one of the main
positions here
one of the main positions in the opening
where the main moves are Queen d2 and
rook c1
yeah there's also a three and solid 92
is my favorite move simply because it
keeps more pieces on the board and makes
it I think somewhat more difficult for
black to find a suitable setup when you
still have all pieces on the board yeah
knight on c6 in particular likes to
exchange itself on d4 and very often
black players do that before
Knight c2 is being played so here I got
to the exact setup that I wanted to
achieve what black normally does here
very often does a special e six and 95
yeah or this attacking the pawn it's
important in this specific line to make
sure that um you are very careful with
the move be three because be three
weakens the long diagonal and squares on
the C file it's a very normal move be
three but specifically here where you
don't have played Queen d2 it can be
very tricky to play this this normal
move yeah here for example I would like
to play b3 but I'm not sure that I'm
really in a position to do so the other
possibility of course is just ninety
five which is how I normally play it but
if I do this now hmm there maybe it's
ninety five CD five there should be two
we are interesting okay so let's think
about the b3 move for a moment the
knight is on a five you don't want to
play b3 when the night comes to e5 but
in this particular position with another
on e5 there's also queen a5 as an
additional problem with the loose pieces
here is 3 and C 3 are I played b3 both
pieces are hanging or and let's say
unprotected and this is always a cause
for concern where you should
double-check and triple-check that you
don't do something stupid but here it
seems I can play b3 and probably I
should do so 9595 CD 5 B should be -
yeah that's really possible
d is 6 okay I can take 1 is 6 Bishop is
three takes on f7 and then this is the
system this is misplaced right okay I
really don't want to play b3 and this
still seems okay 95 CD 5 Bishop b2 D is
6 Bishop takes a three attack on f7
probably rook takes and then we have
equal material no we don't i'm pawn down
okay welcome to the world of counting
wrong hmm okay but still one main point
is that in this position the bishop is
offside on a3 so this is still an
interesting way to play it didn't notice
that I'm set up sacrificing a pawn hmm
interesting but as mentioned it's not
really terrible because it's um okay
it's not doing this at all his King site
is very very weakened okay so I want I
do this I do this now because I think
that here I can play on the C file with
Queen d2 Roxy one and possibly be form
which would ya just trap the night yeah
before I even here why not be for
trapping the this piece
but it tests know where to go to be form
Bishop a1 queen a1 and I'm getting this
piece and F threatening Bishop h6 hmm
yeah that's very interesting
the other thing is though if I play not
who move like Queen d2 how I see ever I
mean then I'm threatening before under
even more favorable circumstances and
the thing is how does he ever even get
the night on from a5 back into play and
move like B 6 assists is completely
unplayable because it weakens the light
squares so much now that's really
interesting B form it's probably good
but it's not necessary on before he
might have looked c3 actually attacking
III and a3 yeah I don't like it before I
don't like it directly let us do this I
mean what is he doing now
and threatening now before under much
more favorable circumstances not right
away this Bishop c3 but yeah he's just
just in a in a in the tricky position
anyway I don't need to rush things here
the only possible counter play would be
f5
and even that is not not not really not
much of a problem where my next move was
rook c1 and then I'm threatening before
a c1 I guess
hmm yeah that's very very a very
difficult position for black you don't
have a simple way to to get the might
begin to play from a 5 as mentioned to
be pawn that's simply not possible to
move there are always ways to use this
entry squares like c6 especially c6 yeah
maybe maybe really f5 I mean so not the
move I would trust very much but you
know it's it's already already very
problematic
you can try Knight e5 intending Knight
c4
but while rook c1 is the next move
anyway controlling C form
I don't really see move him night-night
see five maybe night see five in some
way yeah he went went for this
strategically very undesirable move at
the end okay um yeah before this Bishop
c3a this is just a blunder so I need to
go here this is the the writing for I
guess
yeah and now well I'm not threatening to
win the night know anymore it has to be
seven but what I am threatening is
something like let's say be 497 yeah or
he can play not be seven miles straight
away and then getting at c6 this is some
a very problematic issue so how to start
not be five or like to play this with
the utmost gain of tempo maybe not be
five at first intending something like a
six rook c8 quincy eight night except
for the tempo and then knight c6 you
know our our rook takes Queen takes rook
c1 also possible I am also Percival
yeah an additional problem is that this
night on b7 I mean this is a common
theme in number of openings night sir
in those fianchetto situations right on
b7 especially if white gets in B form
can be very unfortunately a place piece
you know it it has nowhere to go simply
okay so he went for this try to secure
at least c5 let's consider taking and
rook c1 all I can also start with a3 a3
maybe a form I can take play Knight a 76
yeah come on I already shouldn't
shouldn't waste lots of time it's it's a
good position in in a number of ways and
shouldn't be too academic about that 97
to c6 here oops I guess you see one it's
probably both good but I'm not sure if
putting the knight on c6 immediately
assume so beneficial
yeah I expect 95-year and after that if
I go a three there is maybe a for
blocking blocking metas yeah maybe I
should play the tsunami in the slow
fashion p3 a 3d form getting in before
is very useful really taking away the
the blocking square on one c5
yeah now yes art on to this site has set
up maybe is also considering to move the
Queen and then play QuickBooks e8
certainly possible but a move like
between BH then Knight d4 to c6 probably
gained them gains in strength and
strength quite a bit no it wins a temple
now that's really a long thing here
hmm okay but I would probably just play
a knight black forfeits due to
disconnection we be disconnected Chuck
what to do with this game yeah this
happens yeah is it it's a bit short
right to upload it had some interesting
interesting strategic creatures in for
the Roxy point now okay let's let's look
a bit at the moves that were played I
still want to upload it because it might
be useful for players that play this
opening as wide so as mentioned the
knight see - a line here keeps pieces on
the board and he went for for this type
of counter play with the knight coming
here okay and yeah right yeah it's it's
an interesting interesting spot b3 I
didn't want to play okay and actually it
has it has a direct refutation with 94
who which I didn't really didn't really
appreciate I owned it only felt wrong to
me this may be young Jack and Queen b6
this coming okay so b3 was really bad I
went here yeah now the the the critical
line is what what I mentioned in the
video the pawn grab 95c b5 - should be -
this is really what black should do
quite quite clearly I think that's the
way to to question why it's play so I
intended to take only 695 is another
move that can be checked but I intended
to take bishop takes here of course
takes here and yeah actually thought I
might take but there's also this move
black is probably not in bad shape him
he always has some compensation for for
the next for the exchange even if even
if he plays this for example yes
something like this is not not bad at
all for black he's got two pawns he's
got night night ideas no I have this
this this type of play
why does not not worse but black has
some probably decent enough play just
went back a bit too much and if you take
it rook takes do I have enough
compensation here this is what I
initially thought and I miscounted at in
my initial calculation I thought that we
have equal material and with equal
material this position would be very
good for white but a pawn down maybe a
computer wants to do this move and then
fy5 yeah well the King side is weakened
but I doubt that this is really a great
pawn sacrifice
so maybe Bishop h6 is better and there
is this idea that the computer just
suggested 95 okay so here he probably
must grab here on a1 a move like this is
probably just good for white as a7 is
also hanging yeah yeah okay so he should
grab and I recapture this is based on
the fact that the bishop now only has
one move really what about a six just
for argument's sake okay I have I have
Bishop a h-60 to get the exchange back
okay so Bishop d7 er is probably the
right move and now I are interesting
computer place this and the bishops here
they control most of the C file if you
look at this for example the rookies
trap TM I control of all squares we can
go here but this runs into a pretty
naughty self pin with this being
attacked this bomb yeah this is winning
even for what so he needs to maybe do
this returning the exchange yeah and
something like this is probably equal
yeah could have been a very interesting
well he played this and this
unfortunately after the simple capture
on d5 leads to this very unfortunate
position of this night being cut off the
computer here proposes the the radical
Knight takes e4 and take am giving white
a substantial edge but probably this
this kind of stuff is completely
unplayable right
yeah Queen d2 with plus 2.3 yeah b6 is
the only move to avoid immediate
material loss yeah I TM you can you can
argue I mean they played this rather
rather quickly this is the computer
suggestion maybe this is even even
better more forceful keeping this on the
board yeah yeah yeah I'm this is this is
better and then look be more
with before coming that's even stronger
than my plane it both is very very good
but that's probably a bit more forceful
you know but it's it's there are many
many ways to to play yeah and here well
I had expected night B to C 5 and from
them you will need to decide what you do
of course this is one idea the night is
nicely placed on c6 but it's not the
only idea you can also try to get this
e3 before and if you go a3 now however
there is this possibility with a for now
or a move later no black can't play this
for example and now be force to be
avoided
I don't like a3 this is a bit too direct
you can if you want to play for this you
can do this the slow there's no way
while not blundering that b3 of course
and the other ideas ok simply to play
this night here Knight to c6 possibly
Bishop b5 invading on the light squares
the thing that he the the the variation
that the engineer proposed with Ruby one
is better really this is also
substantially advantageous for white but
the computer line was even even a bit
more convincing all right unfortunately
it is connected but what can you do
thanks for watching